we've got a question for you Cinderella
and Charmaine why did your son turn out
to be a total vk' we're not blaming you
guys or anything we're just curious to
find out where Chad's snotty attitude
comes from today acts like a villain but
deep down we know Chad just wants to
dance take selfies and watch movies with
Audrey so we guess he's not that bad
but for your sake Cinderella we hope tad
doesn't marry Audrey you already had a
wicked stepmother so the last thing you
need is a wicked daughter-in-law Chad
wasn't exactly the best sidekick the
queen of mean could have asked for after
all he did loke save our Don here are 10
things no one realizes about Chad in
descendants 3 well maybe just a lackey
to do your bidding change tires smoothie
runs huh Chad charming might not be the
sharpest tool in the shed but he
definitely knows that Audrey's using him
but he just doesn't care he listened to
Audrey's rants and knows that all she
wants in life is to be the queen of
auradon but to do that she has to marry
Ben oddly enough Chad doesn't seem to
mind he was equally as shocked and
outraged as Audrey when Ben proposed to
mouth turns out Chad supports Audrey and
wants to see her dreams come true Chad
and Audrey haven't been together for a
long time but he knows her a lot better
than Ben ever did Chad knows exactly
what to say to get on Audrey's good side
during Jane's birthday party Chad
friends out of the woods and cut
Audrey's speech in half
she looks furious until he compliments
her new look
Chad then offers Audrey his loyalty and
asks to be of service to her say what
you want about Chad but the guy did
manage to escape the sleep spell and
record speed another thing we notice is
that chad is terrified of magic most of
the AKS grew up with the notion that
magic is bad but for some reason Chad
developed a big-time fear he was
petrified of Audrey Spectre and never
took a liking to mal
come on Chad give them a chance he also
turned on Eevee the second he found out
she was using her magic mirror Chad may
love technology and 3d printers but he
appears to hate magic with a passion but
his hatred doesn't end there just like
Audrey Chad doesn't seem to like the vks
he was brought up thinking and they were
dangerous and evil so he never really
gave them a chance what do you think
villains teach their kids kindness
Fairplay no way okay
this is made crystal clear in
descendents 3 when Ben in the B Ches
rescue chat from the broom closet
tablet terrified until he recognized the
Ben's face in the end that Chad and
Audrey have always wanted the VKS
to stay on the aisle but here's the
difference between Chad and Audrey Chad
may not like the B case but he doesn't
want to cause them any harm as Audrey
sidekick he's supposed to help her mess
with her enemies but in the scene where
Audrey asks Chad to help her mess with
the vks Chad tries to suggest other
activities chat tries to distract Audrey
with movies online shopping and salad
which gets him thrown into the closet in
the end Chad tried to help the B Ches
so can he really be that evil if
something were to happen what do you
think it'd be in line to be king believe
it or not but there's proof that chad is
actually a good guy and we have Jane to
thank for that we can all agree that
Jane is kind giving and an all-around
good person so that makes us wonder what
Chad was doing at her birthday party
Audrey wasn't invited to the party but
Chad was which means that he's good
friends with Jane and if Jane sees
something good and tad then we do too
but while Chad may have some good
qualities he also has a bunch of bad
ones chad is kind of annoying there's no
use in denying it he's constantly poking
fun at people and we even see him trying
to convince Jane but Carlos forgot her
birthday luckily some of Jane's friends
started taking selfies which got him off
of Jane's back
turns out Cinderella's son is social
media crazy he can't bear to miss out on
a good selfie with friends it's clear as
day that Chad loves Audrey she got a
flat tire in Sherwood Forest and she
wants me to go fix it
that's six hours away really only six
even when she's the biggest threat to
ours on but some might say that he's a
little too desperate for her affection
did you guys notice how audrey was
treating tad like a dog in descendants
three she was literally petting his head
and the worst of all is that Chad
actually enjoying it and the smile on
his face says it all
Chad may be a pushover when it comes to
Audrey but he wasn't exactly a faithful
sidekick
Chad saw Jane getting into the enchanted
lake during the sleep spell but he chose
to keep it to himself if he hadn't done
that Jane would never have told Ben what
was happening and help ceviches save
Arden so in his own special way Todd
helped save our town from Audrey's
fierce grass but if there's one thing we
noticed about Chad in descendents three
is that he has a space in his heart for
forgiveness despite what Audrey put him
through we see him standing by her side
at the end of the movie and he welcomes
the BK's to our John with open arms
turns out Chad isn't that all bad now
that you know a little bit more about
Chad charming do you still see him as a
low-key villain or do you see him as one
of the many heroes of descendants three
sound off in the comments section is
Chad the hero of descendants three
thanks for watching don't forget to give
us a big thumbs up and be sure to
subscribe so you never miss another
video we'll catch you next time on the
things
[Music]